we're going to take a look at how cloud
code makes it easy to develop for
kubernetes to develop for kubernetes you
need to setup kubernetes configuration
for your project find how to efficiently
iterate on your code on kubernetes and
learn how to perform common development
tasks on kubernetes like debugging but
it can be challenging to master all the
necessary config slow and error-prone to
perform the repetitive tasks of building
pushing and deploying images and
difficult to setup debugging against a
kubernetes cluster that's why we built
cloud code cloud code is a set of
development tools for google cloud that
includes ide extensions for visual
studio code and JetBrains IDs such as
intelligent cloud code helps you author
kubernetes config with completions
linting inline documentation and code
snippets it automates the process of
running and updating your coat on
kubernetes and so much more that we
don't have time to talk about it all
today to get started with cloud code
download it from your favorite IDE s
extension marketplace let's take a look
at cloud code for vs code in action
we'll get started by using cloud code to
create a new kubernetes project cloud
code also works with your existing
applications as well first select the
cloud code venue from the task bar and
select new application
[Music]
next choose the language and template
you want to use
I'll choose nodejs hello world finally
name your project and hit enter to
create it now that your project has been
created let's take a look at the
kubernetes config expand kubernetes
manifests and select hello service dot
llamo since this is a starter
application the Yambol is already here
for us but if it wasn't you could use
control space to view the available
snippets for kubernetes config files to
create your own from scratch here let's
just see how cloud code helps add a new
property to the spec I can return to the
next line and use control space again to
see completions for possible properties
external traffic policy looks
interesting let's take a look at that
cloud code offers inline documentation
here and on hover for all these
kubernetes types after accepting
external traffic policy let's try
setting it to none looks like a dinner
read the documentation well enough cloud
codes linting is telling me I need to
use cluster or local let's use cluster
now that we've seen how cloud code helps
manage your kubernetes ii Hamill let's
see how it helps you deploy to
kubernetes first we need a cluster to
deploy to let's move over to the cloud
code view
[Music]
I went ahead and created a google
kubernetes engine cluster from cloud
code earlier by clicking this button but
you can add any kubernetes cluster
including local ones such as docker or
mini cube to deploy we select cloud code
from the taskbar gun and select run on
kubernetes I'll confirm the cluster I
want to deploy to confirm a default
image registry for my Google Cloud
project and cloud code begins the
deployment
it looks like the deployment has
completed successfully so let's take a
look by command clicking the IP address
shown in the output window when we
return the cloud code we see that watch
mode is on that means I can make a code
change and it will automatically be
redeployed let's give that a try I'll
expand the source folder select app
touch a yes and change hello world
- hello debts and save the file we can
see that cloud code is automatically
redeploying the service and we can
return to the web browser refresh and
see the updated page let's see what it
looks like to debug a kubernetes app
with cloud code I'll go to the run and
debug view select debug on kubernetes
and click the play button we see in the
output that the debugger is attached so
let's set a breakpoint in the app.js
file and reload the page
[Music]
the breakpoint hit and we can see all
the utility that we expect with the
debugger even with code running on a
kubernetes cluster you just learned how
cloud code lets you focus on writing
code like you always have and spend less
time learning an endless set of new
tools and technology just to be
productive on kubernetes
[Music]